and actually name please
Thomas Middleditch five-foot-ten and
some change okay all right
did you want to try it in the costume
sure yeah okay
it does not do too it does not do to
dwell
it does not do does not do Scout doesn't
make any sense
speaks in riddles a little bit this is
just original dialogue of this from the
original dialogue yeah the official
script is it now yes we're just using
official Dumbledore from what book I
think it's from all seven of the Harry
Potter books
what okay I don't know it's from a
series of fantasy books but a young
magician very literally right sorry Lord
of the Rings no it's it's Harry Potter
okay Kendall I'll do it as Kendall oh it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to leave Hobbit who shall not
pass Gandalf all right you shall not
pass it's great
[Music]
Hobbit some kind of oh man great
- the well-organized mind death is but
the next great adventure
Hobart okay it is from Harry Potter not
the Lord of the Ring got it
so there's no hobbits in their heart
there aren't sure it's fantasy you're
sure it's not sure I got a beard on a
beard and I have my own beard can't
reduce I mean you're supposed to be it's
supposed to be teen you actually got a
whole thing
so the well-organised mine death is
about the next great adventure whatever
okay we've got that okay yeah that works
there
oh hey happiness can be found even the
darkness of times if one only remembers
to turn on the light try a night at envy
where you enjoy the other thing we use
gonna cycle and I like just gonna have
respective selves any good
yeah that's here that's good okay I took
a leap great we got a lot okay great
good so you have enough absolutely when
you do anything again no I think we're
good okay cool
thanks thank you
see second I know amazing yeah it's
pretty easy for me actually a lot of
people say acting tired I'm not it's
actually really easy
great like the whole thing it was easy
to get here just you know ways I don't
think easy to drag it just over the
Hollywood
cool I think we got it okay great